[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello again the audience this is a
discussion about time
past and future worlds we can never
inhabit we live of necessity in the
present but physicists and philosophers
with very different outlooks from
Einstein to Derrida claim the present is
an illusion it's time not a river at all
but instead a static dimension are we
deluded by experience intimate imagining
that the present is real or our I'm
Stein's space-time universe and
Derrida's attack on the metaphysics of
presents fundamental errors and here we
have a very illustrious panel to discuss
this complex and fascinating theme we
have Julian Barbour to my right Julian
is a British physicist whose research
focuses on quantum gravity and the
history of science I have here on my far
left is Emily Thomas who's a historian
of the philosophy of time based at
Durham University and she works on
various ideas from the nature of time to
the relationship between philosophy and
travel and she's the author of absolute
time and here immediately on my left I
have Tim maudlin who's a professor of
philosophy at NYU and a world leader in
the field of the philosophy of physics
and he's the author of the philosophy of
physics space and time and the crucial
question I'm going to pose now is is
time and illusion and I'm going to start
with Emily Thomas thank you Emily thank
you very much ok so the idea that time
is an illusion it's something that
philosophers have wondered about for two
and a half thousand years the idea that
time is just an appearance and not just
time that change is just an appearance
was worried about back with the
pre-socratics what it's quite new
relatively is the idea that now that the
present moment might or might not be in
a lieu
so I think that about a hundred years
ago people who thought that time was
real conceived time to be static a kind
of block universe in which past present
future are all real and a saw time has
kind of like a fourth dimension of space
so in in the same way that in space you
can move in any direction and no
direction is privileged I think people
thought the same about time there were
various reasons why that was so say
things like timelines had become really
popular they were invented in 1765 the
very idea of plotting events on a
timeline is something that's quite new
and as soon as you start to think about
events on a line you have something
that's static a line is something that
doesn't move and I think that's one of
the things that led people to think
about time it is a static dimension what
you then get in late 19th early 20th
century is an absolute rebellion against
this idea say people like Henri Bergson
in France and after Eddington in Britain
began saying no no if you think that
there's that time is just like space
that it means that there's nothing
special about the present moment
there's no now that's ever moving ever
flowing forwards you just have moments
of time spread out and there's nothing
special about now and they really
disliked that view they thought that on
the contrary there is something really
special about the present that we feel
time flowing and moving forwards and and
that people who think about time as
being static and the present is just
being an illusion that they're just
missing out on this fundamental feature
of the world I soon I think this is how
this debate got started whether or not
the president is illusion
I think it all kicked off about a
hundred years ago brilliant thank you
that's very helpful as background to
this debate Julian I want to ask you
same question is time delusion Julian
Barbour the experience of time is
definitely not an illusion that I'm that
I'm quite sure of I'm not mad
however I do think there is no such
thing as time paradoxically I would say
that there are lots of things that I
would be prepared to call instance of
time or rather now's and I would liken
them the simplest example I always
travel around with two triangles to
explain my theory of the whole universe
and it works quite well the my concept
of a now is just something which is
structured and is in space and the
simplest example I can give of that and
it's amazing how much of mathematics
comes from it it's a triangle
so my simplest model of a universe would
be three particles which are in space
and let it be simple Euclidean space and
in any instant they are at the vertices
of a triangle so that for me is one now
and here's another one
it's slightly different and or if you
conceive of all possible triangles
that's a possibility space and I would
say these are all potential now's and we
are in one of them now in an incredibly
complicated richly structured one and I
think it's the nature of that incredible
rich structure which somehow rather the
brain in passing from the structure
which is in the brain and giving us a
narrative in our consciousness lead us
to believe that time is flowing it's
really all encoded in our brains now but
that's all there is I think if we had no
experience of change we would we just
couldn't have the idea of time passing
but I actually I do so much like that
word
change as much as I used to because it
implies going forwards in time that
there's a direction to it so I now
prefer to use the word difference these
two triangles are different and for me
the absolute minimum that you need to
develop a notion of time which will
stand scientific scrutiny is structures
spatial structures which are different
and you need lots of them so that's my
opening pitch great brilliant Thank You
Gillian and I want stamps Tim maudlin
now to pose the question again is timely
allusion Tim no great you want to take
more time to expand so I I'm I'm kind of
a everyday guy on the street in this
debate for many purposes amazingly I can
actually put bread on the table going
around giving lectures defending the
thesis the time passes sure it does yeah
and and to me the question is kind of
interesting question is why there's a
debate about this at all let me make a
couple quick historical comments you can
entertain the possibility that things
are illusions Descartes very famously in
the first meditation sat down to ask
himself what can I be
absolutely certain about and by
reflecting on the fact that he dreams he
actually got himself to a state of
saying I'm not even sure there's an
external world out there right maybe
it's all just in my head so in a way all
of spatial reality in two paragraphs
Descartes could put his finger on
questioning it but it never even
occurred to him to question time right
even if you're asleep and dreaming time
is passing things are happening the the
events happen in a certain sequence the
it does go back to antiquity as was
mentioned but the the main culprit there
was Parmenides who had a very peculiar
logical argument to the effect that you
can't coherently talk about the
non-existence of anything and
followed from that since change was that
which is not coming to be he said well
that which is not is incoherent so
change had to go as well he had a
certain kind of heroic valor in
following this argument out to its end
and believing it but it is kind of crazy
so my view is short time is real time
doesn't have the temporal structure of
the world isn't what we thought it was
we learned from relativity that it has a
different structure than you might
naively think but the claim that time is
an illusion I think is is is a very odd
one and I can't really think of any
strong arguments to believe it
great thank you that's an excellent sort
of triumvirate of views that we've
really got on the panel and so I'm going
to turn to I think we're going to talk a
little bit more about concepts of time
obviously there are myriad concepts of
time
Shakespeare talked about the whirligig
of time Marvelle talked about times a
winged chariot in slightly less poetic
terms we hear from science about time
dilation simultaneity and so on I'm
going to turn to one of these theories
to sort of get us into the debate which
is the idea of the growing block
universe theory another not massively
poetic sounding theory and I wondered
Emily if you could put this in some
context what is growing block universe
theory and why is it so fashionable at
the moment what's going on so if you are
a growing block theorist you think that
the past is real but the future is
unreal to continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a I dot TV
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas